صاروخ سبيس اكس هذا يحمل 60 قمرا صناعيا
لمدارها في الفضاء وخلال الاعوام المقبله
يامل الى ماسك ان يوفر خدمه الانترنت
للعالم عبر شركته ستار لينك من خلال
42,000 قمراعي وهو رقم يزيد ب 15 ضعفا عن
عدد الاقمار الصناعيه التي تدور حاليا
الارض
الغايه ايصال خدمه انترنت رخيصه وسريعه
للعالم وايضا ان يقتطع حصه من ارباح قطاع
الاتصالات العالمي ما سيسمح لشركته بربح
ما يتراوح بين 30 و50 مليار دولار سنويا
حاله تطبيق الخطه
اقمار ماسك الصناعيه لخدمه الانترنت تتميز
بان مدارها حول الارض اقرب من مثيلاتها
التابعه للدول او الشركات الاخرى ماذا
يقلل من انقطاع او تاخر الانترنت لدى
المستقبلين ايضا سترتبط اقمار ستار لينك
مع بعضها بشعاع الليزر ما يجعلك قادرا على
استخدام الانترنت بشكل مستمر وانت غير
القمر الذي يكون وقتها فوق منزلك لكن
الامر لا يخلو من جوانب سلبيه فازدحام
المدارس بالاقمار الصناعيه قد يزيد من
صعوبه رؤيه الاجسام او الكويتبات التي قد
تصطدم بالارض اضافه لذلك قد تعيق الاقمار
الصناعيه البحث عن كواكب عقوب سوداء جديده
اما الامر الاخطر فهو تلبد مدار الارض
بالشظايا في حال ارتطام الاقمار الصناعيه
ببعضها البعض او تصادم الشظايا المتطايره
ببعضها لكن خبراء يقولون ان الاخطار
المحرقه بمدار الارض لن تذبح رغبه الدول
او الشركات بغزو الفضاء حسن جوليد العربيه